look chris here's the thing
until there is a daily test that can be
administered and administered quickly
with a reliable result
this risk is going to be there that
there's going to be an outbreak and it
was no more stark to me than when i
looked at the protocol that was sent by
the nfl on sunday to all teams for what
needs to happen in the facility access
to specific areas who's allowed to be
where six feet of distance in locker
rooms the extreme kind of stuff that we
see throughout society
but for the nfl
eventually you're going to be on a
football field blocking and tackling and
in close quarters so there's a
disconnect there that just seems odd to
me and i don't think there's any
replacement ultimately for a daily test
that clears each player
from the virus before they actually go
onto a practice field or go into a game
because there's one guy that gets out
there who's got it and they're all
pressed together in that scrum for in
the case of a game three hours how many
other guys are going to end up with it
so that to me is the donut hole that
needs to be filled
no i know and i i don't know how it gets
filled then you're right i mean a lot of
this stuff we can take all the
precautions and sanitize and social
distance all we want and do all those
things but you're right until we have
you know some sort of uh
daily test or whatever it is
it's going to be tough and you know we
saw last week like with the alabama
football players you got together with a
workout right there was a bunch of guys
there that ended up testing positive i
think one guy had gone to one of the
protests he acquired the you know the
covet 19 and it spread to a few other
guys you know these these are real
issues and what's going to go on with
the team if okay yeah not five guys but
35 guys all of a sudden come down with
it i don't get that but at the very
least i think what what we're talking
about here is mike just continuing to
make our best efforts as you know with
the football organizations to keep
everybody clean do all the right things
to hopefully
when guys do go out in the field and hit
each other and sweat on each other and a
little blood swapped and whatever else
that hey we've done our due diligence
and we've really tried our hardest and
we've been very strict about you know
keeping these guys healthy and not
having coba 19 to where maybe you can
get out there and practice and feel good
that you've you've limited your chances
and hopefully nobody has it and you see
where it goes from there but i don't
think anything's going to get done until
you're right the testing is uh a little
more exact
32 guys or 32 teams excuse me 55 guys as
of this year on the game day roster and
of course 46 will actually suit up let's
do 32 times 46. uh 32 times 46 is 1472
players on any given sunday or monday or
thursday when you look at the league
collectively who will be in a position
to go onto a field
one guy all it takes is one who slips
through the crack positive gets out
there on the field and starts passing it
around you got a problem until they have
quick effective testing that is
administered on a daily basis that risk
is going to be there and i hope to god
for the sake of the nfl and for the sake
of the rest of the world
at the point in september or sooner than
that where you can have that kind of
quick turnaround testing so people will
know whether or not they are positive or
negative
you